peuple
[Musique]
désastre aux états unis athex a cité un
navire français pesant soudainement
explosion dans le fort a mis le feu aux
usines de la ville pendant plusieurs
jours les explosions ont succédé aux
explosions en une chaîne infernale qui
happe et de texas it est un immense
brasier
plus de 600 morts des milliers de
blessés
les deux tiers des maisons détruites
d'ex incité n'est plus aujourd'hui que
neville sur laquelle semble s'être
abattue la mort atomique
mauvaise semaine aux états unis
[Musique]
brest déjà ravagé par la guerre vient de
connaître une catastrophe semblable à
celle qui a passé texas était tous les
baraquements du port et les 5000
constructions qui abritait
provisoirement la population de brest
ont été ravagés par l'explosion du cargo
ocean libertés chargé de nitrate
d'ammonium
[Musique]
à plusieurs kilomètres du lieu du
sinistre des vitres ont été fracassées
et les façades souple et 21 morts et 120
blessés
700 millions de dégâts tel est le
premier bilan du désastre
les brestois cependant refuse de quitter
le port et déjà ils tentent de sauver ce
qui reste de leurs pauvres d'honneur
mauvaise semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]